hoch oben in den bergen in guarda lebt
noch schläge im heimatdorf vom stellen
ausliegen
die geschichte 1945 von der
schriftstellerin selina künstler dach
ist auch seine geschichte
wer etwas über nord schlegels leben
erfahren will muss zwei dinge tun ihn
beim vornamen nennen und mit ihm
durchgeht spazieren
[Musik]
walt disney höchstpersönlich hat den
narren an der schellen ursli erzählung
gefressen
so wird das kleine bergdorf 1953 zur
großen filmkulisse der bauernbub
vorziehen soll beim alljährlichen winter
aus leuten beim schalander marz
mitlaufen aber mit dem kleinsten
glöckchen
das kommt für ihn nicht in frage
er macht sich auf die lebensgefährliche
suche nach einer großen glocke am ende
kommt was ihn als held ins dorf zurück
die einzigen erinnerungen an die
dreharbeiten sind eine handvoll
fotografie
aus dem zehnjährigen ort wird ein film
darsteller ein glücksfall für die
bauernfamilie für mich das wie die
filmarbeiten werden für ihn zur
befreiung der strenge alltag zwischen
stall und schule ist weit weg
stattdessen zeigt schlegel dem
internationalen kamerateam was er kann
klettert ungesichert in den engadiner
felsen für mich ist normal
ebenso unkompliziert war die
zusammenarbeit mit dem regisseur ernst
heiniger im auftrag von walt disney
inszeniert der thurgauer im unterengadin
noch in den 1950 er jahren realisiert er
weitere filme für disney einiger werke
emma girls und grand canyon erhalten je
einen oscar
nur weil eine schelle mosley adaption
geplant wurde wurde man auf die erste
verfilmung aufmerksam
das ist schon mal gesehen und wer nicht
an jetzt an neuen film kokowääh
denn hat kein mensch preist der
simoncelli außer seiner ehefrau tilly
schlegel
sie spielt damals stellen aus lees
schwester florina im gegensatz zum
hauptdarsteller kann sich die junge
tilly gar nicht für die filmarbeit
begeistern
der erste schellen ursli film ist bis
heute nicht mehr auffindbar
angeblich lief er im vorprogramm us
amerikanischen kinos chili und nord
schlegel haben sich kurz nach den
dreharbeiten verliebt
heute sind sie 50 jahre verheiratet
den fertigen film würde noch schlegel
sehr gerne sehen auch wenn er den
schluss der geschichte bestens kennt
alle bleiben stehen vor freude dass sie
den ostsee